president Trump's threat to deploy
federal troops in US cities in response
to protests over the death of George
Floyd is raising concerns the military
is being politicized former defense
secretary Robert Gates served eight
presidents in various roles including
George W Bush and Barack Obama his new
book is exercise of power American
failures successes and a new path
forward in the post-cold war world it
looks at the leadership and foreign
policy decisions of recent presidents
including President Trump secretary
Gates joins us now good morning
secretary gates thanks for being with us
I want to start with this sort of recent
clash if you will between military
leaders in President Trump
defense secretary mark Esper and other
leaders spoke out against the
president's calls to use the military in
containing the protests what kind of
impact do you think that has when the
military and and and the
commander-in-chief clash like that
publicly well every president that I
worked for and particularly the two that
I worked for a secretary of defense had
their disagreements with the military
and always the president prevails when
when he feels strongly about something I
think that the real issue for the
military leaders in this recent incident
instance was the question of using
Regular Army forces in Washington and
other cities rather than the National
Guard
the truth is Regular Army forces are
drink trained to do one thing and that's
kill our enemies they're not trained in
law enforcement they're not trained in
crowd control the National Guard is and
so when you look at an army uniform you
see very little difference between the
National Guard and Regular Army but
there really is a difference in terms of
their training and and the purposes for
which they are intended so I think that
was the issue that concerned a lot of
the former military leaders you've said
that that every president uses the
military as a prop at some point but
that this president has taken it to a
new level the chairman of the
Chiefs mark Milley apologized for
appearing at a photo op in a park across
from the White House and and I'm
wondering what you thought of that photo
op well I thought it was unfortunate and
and frankly I felt like the military
leadership was being exploited I think
they got themselves into a situation
that they didn't expect and an afterword
regret it and that was the basis for
general Millie's apology I think he was
very sensitive to the appearance of the
American military being political and
one of the fundamental tenets for our
men and women in uniform is being
apolitical and serving all of the
American people not just one president
or one party or another you and other
military leaders have voiced support for
changing the names of military bases
that are they're named in honor of
Confederate generals the president is
does not support that idea at least at
this point why do you think first of all
why do you think those bases have held
those names for so long and why do you
think it's right to change them now I
can't answer the reason why-y-y they've
lasted so long I think hardly it's just
inertia partly the the names do have
some meaning to to the troops who were
trained there or served there but I
think the time has come and I think the
events of the last couple of weeks and
the killing of George Floyd and and the
demonstrations have presented us with an
opportunity to make a change where you
know when we have these bases named for
Confederate generals it suggests we're
celebrating them and my view is we can't
rewrite history but we need to
understand it we need to remember it but
we don't need to celebrate it and I
think that's why the time has come to
change the names of these military
facilities I mean it's always puzzled me
why we don't have a Fort George
Washington or
for patent or or or a facility name for
an african-american Medal of Honor
recipient so I think it's an opportunity
really to to make the change at this
point as you've pointed out the military
in many ways for a long time led to
integration in this country but general
Charles Brown jr. just became the first
African American to lead to lead one of
the nation's military services as chief
of staff of the Air Force why do you why
do you think that took so long given the
history of integration in the military
well it clearly took too long we have
had African Americans in senior
leadership positions Colin Powell's
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
General Lloyd Austin was the commander
in Iraq when I was secretary but but the
truth is that at the four-star rank
there are too few and too far between
and I think a general Milley is has
turned his attention to that and the
attention of the other chiefs in terms
of the promotion processes to make sure
that that more African Americans are and
other minorities are promoted into the
most senior leadership positions in the
Pentagon it's it's it's really it's not
in I mean they will be qualified there's
no question in my mind about that but
there just needs to be more attention
paid to make sure making sure that
minority leaders have the opportunity to
be in the most senior positions do you
think there's been a systemic problem I
think so and probably in all of the
services I think the recent events
frankly have have I think been a turning
point you know in the attitudes of a lot
of people and I think it's really
grabbed the attention of the senior
military leadership as well we the
military as you say was out in front in
terms of integration and providing
opportunities for African Americans long
before the rest of the society but but
in particularly in terms of promoting
leaders to the most senior positions and
frankly
some thread of racism there still needs
to be attention paid to this in the
military and and as I would say more
attention as we go forward you say
they've been a turning point for a lot
of people mr. secretary have they been a
turning point for you in some way I
think so I I think that you know I think
what many of us missed and and I feel
like I've been an inclusive leader in
the in the organizations that I've led
but I don't think many of us fully
appreciated the day-to-day kind of
humiliations and and and difficulties
that African Americans even the most
successful African Americans have had to
deal with and I think I think that's
really come to the fore in the last two
or three weeks in a way for many of us
that had not been particularly evident
before that all right secretary gates
thank you so much for being with us this
morning exercise of power is on sale
today and we will be right back